Hi, and welcome to the course.
This course will be the first of series'
of courses where you will learn to build
great products.
>> We thought a lot about whether
entrepreneurship can be taught.
And there are many courses and
reference materials out there.
But we wondered whether that material,
or
series of courses could really
transform someone into an entrepreneur.
Someone that is an unconventional
hacker, a risk taker, and
a jack of all trades.
>> Successful entrepreneurship is
a lot more than the inner workings of
a company, or
the character of the founders.
It involves a number of external factors
which make it extremely difficult
to have a single formula for success.
Every moment in history
will only happen once.
There would be only one Airbnb.
There wouldn't be any other Google.
Fortunately, there are plenty of
other problems left for you to solve.
>> Yeah, and this course is designed
to teach you some practices and
processes that Silicon Valley
companies have developed
over the past few years on how to create
beautiful and meaningful products.
We hope you can use them
as our framework to build
a business of your own.
>> Because start ups are risky and
costly business,
it is always wise to validate early on,
build only what you need, and not more.
And iterate as fast as you can.
Throughout this course we'll
talk to several start-ups
who have done just that.
Let's hear from them now.